this is the the new turkey digital
office which is the center for akhtar
tease digital operations towards the the
general elections on the 7th of June
it's an unprecedented office which is
probably the first of its kind in Turkey
we have 180 people here all together of
course we've been inspired by some other
works by of the Obama campaign campaigns
in UK and even in India last year we
learned a lot about social media use of
social media and digital platforms
htp is the most critical actor in these
elections because if the party passes
the ten percent threshold the governing
party will fail to form a single-party
government
what differentiates us from other
parties is that our social media
campaign is mostly grassroots campaign
we have a limited budget that's why we
are using our activists are supervisors
and the day there is almost a nationwide
mobilization in the country these days
to help you help HTTP as the threshold
social media has become the most
critical area or elections campaign the
total number of twitter users switch
from two million to 10 million doing is
a protest and the turkey is one of the
country's highest number of facebook
users
you